[Music]
you're watching the daily climate show
on sky news coming up on today's
programme
making coal a thing of the past an
iconic chimney at scotland's last plant
powered by the fossil fuel comes
crashing down
why 30 000 trees could be felled this
winter as global warming drives disease
and under the sea how fish songs are
helping researchers understand the
health of coral reefs
[Music]
hello and welcome to the uk's only daily
climate news show where we track the
changes happening to our world right now
and challenge those coming up with the
solutions
now an iconic chimney stack from
scotland's last remaining coal-fired
power station has been demolished today
the fife plant produced coal-fired
energy until its ceased operating in
2016
but today's demolition was a symbolic
part of the beginning of the end of the
fossil fuel era a warning this report
from our correspondent molina
veselinovich contains some flash
photography
scotland's last remaining coal power
plant consigned to history
the chimney at longanite station has
stood in fife for 50 years but today its
demolition signaled the end of an era
i think this is a really special day
it's a poignant day and it will no doubt
generate mixed emotions for people
who've worked in this city over 50 years
but it symbolizes that transition
scotland is making away from fossil
fuels to renewable low carbon sources of
energy it marks the definitive end of
coal in scotland which is such an
important moment
it was a symbolic act
scotland has been curl free since 2016
when longanite was closed by scottish
power a bit sad and emotional this time
just now here i've been here 13 years
and she just said it's the end of an era
but one of the biggest challenges was
making sure that communities that were
built around the fossil fuel industry
don't get left behind one of the things
that made me most proud of what we've
done here is that overwhelmingly all of
the people who wanted a new job we found
them a new career we helped people who
wanted to go and retire or to go and
find careers elsewhere and that's a it's
massively important that people
communities the whole country feels like
it's going in this transition
longan had once generated nearly half of
scotland's power
in its final act it beamed warning
stripes showing the rise in temperature
from 1850 to 2020
and a message urging a greener more
sustainable future milena vaseline rich
sky news
so as melina mentioned scotland has been
coal free since 2016 but the fossil fuel
does still make up a small percentage of
the electricity mix in great britain and
you can see on our data dashboard here
that right now it accounts for around
four percent of the mix while 46 of
electricity is coming from gas we've got
25 coming from renewables and we've got
11 there coming from nuclear well
joining me now is julian leslie head of
networks and chief engineer at the
national grid electricity system
operator
welcome to you so how close is britain
to completely eliminating coal
uh pretty close actually as you've said
i mean we're producing four percent now
but on average across this year and last
year coal is sort of around one and a
half to one point six percent of our
total energy need which is down 97 since
2012 so we've made tremendous progress
here in the uk
and by october 2024 that will be the end
of coal
on the whole of the gb electricity
system
and yet we are still relying on fossil
fuels through gas aren't we so how long
is that going to be necessary
um so gas is a hugely flexible and
transitional fuel um we have an ambition
within the system operator that we'll
have a few hours in 2025 or we'll be
able to run the uk system without any
fossil fuel generation whatsoever so
zero carbon
uh and obviously as we heard uh the
conservative
party conference a couple weeks ago that
by 2035 we will have a zero carbon
electricity system here in the uk
so we can rely solely on renewables for
our energy in the future i mean isn't
there a worry about relying on the wind
and the sun to do their bit all the time
sure you need a diverse energy mix and
in the uk we're very fortunate because
we do have nuclear we have some hydro
and we've got
interconnection to mainland europe as
well and and just this autumn actually
we commissioned that one of the largest
sub-sea cables in the world over to
norway and linking those two energy
systems together so more solutions like
that connecting us to our close
neighbors
uh and building more storage but also
the flexibility consumers will have a
much bigger role to play into the future
and although your daily life you'll be
able to go and do the normal things you
do normally you'll have a smart black
box somewhere that's controlling
actually when does the washing machine
come on when does your vehicle elect
your vehicle charge etc so huge
flexibility will come forward to move
the demand the amount of electricity you
consume
to when it's being generated by the
human electricity
julian leslie thanks very much indeed
so let's take a look at the day's other
climate news now and russia recorded the
second largest temperature difference
for a single day in any country
yesterday according to the met office
minus 61 degrees was recorded at
delianke while temperatures reached 24
degrees in chateau that's a temperature
difference of 85 degrees celsius
new research published in the journal
nature has found hydropower developments
are one of the major drivers of habitat
loss for tigers the dams create massive
reservoirs which drown out the homes of
the big cat species
421 dams were damaged
damaging almost 14 000 square kilometers
of tiger habitat in asia and a further
41 dams are planned in their territorial
range
and europe's largest living wall is set
to be finished in 2023 as part of a
12-storey office development in salford
eden designed and built by the english
cities fund will include 355 000 plants
with the aim of removing toxins from the
atmosphere the 36 million pound building
will also feature insect hotels and bird
nesting boxes in an effort to increase
biodiversity
the national trust is warning that 30
000 trees will need to be felled this
winter because of diseases made worse by
climate change the charity says there
could be dramatic changes to the british
countryside as milder wetter winters and
warmer summers caused by global warming
are creating ideal conditions for
diseases and pests to spread assadia
chowdery reports
you could call this a pandemic an
invisible disease that's spreading fast
among large trees here in the lake
district
at the heart of one of the uk's top
beauty spots
thousands of trees have already
disappeared off the horizon
2019 that was like a completely covered
landscape with trees treason
you know a full woodland the scale of
how many trees that we've actually lost
in the last three years due to the
phytophthora remorum
the disease can kill a tree in weeks
it's detected using a lateral flow test
similar to what we use to test for covid
so from this one tree this one location
everything within 300 meters has to be
killed so if we get a scattering of
trees
there
over the woodland the whole woodland can
go that's what's happened here
over in the peak district another
disease ash trees infected with ash
dieback have to be removed and it's
costing millions of pounds it's
estimated that up to 95 percent of the
uk's ash trees will be lost in the next
20 to 30 years
there is no solution to this problem
foresters simply have to start from
scratch and plant new trees
we need to be thinking about the new
treescapes that we want for britain and
what those treescapes should look like
building into them some resilience so
that they cope with climate change so
that they deal with some of the issues
that are facing us
the national trust has carried out
extensive felling of larches here over
the last four years
and it's still taking place
larches are useful trees not only are
their barks highly resistant to decay
but they also drop their needles which
means sunlight can come through right
onto the forest floor where other
species can thrive and where there are
rows of larches they also provide
crucial protection to other weaker trees
in the path of a storm
when storm arwen hit this area last week
these trees crashed into a lakeside
holiday park the national trust says it
may have lost tens of thousands of trees
last weekend
the few remaining ones are left exposed
and pose a risk to human life
they may also now have to be cut down
sadia chowdhury sky news in windermere
in the lake district
fish songs are helping show the success
of a coral reef restoration project in
indonesia researchers have found that
underwater noises are a sure sign of a
healthy diverse soundscape and can be
used alongside visual observations to
monitor these vital ecosystems so let's
have a listen
fish being silent is actually one of the
biggest lies that anyone's ever been
told they make loads of different types
of noise
coral reefs in particular
are the noisiest ecosystems in the sea
by contrast when a reef is degraded it
sounds very quiet because none of the
life is there what we did in this study
was to go to somewhere where they had
for years and years been regrowing the
coral and trying to rebuild the
ecosystem in that way and for the first
time we were able to test whether that
re-growing of the coral had rebuilt that
whole ecosystem whether all those noisy
animals had come back or not
and to our to our delights we we found
that they had
but i think what this gives us is a real
encouragement that if we can get rid of
the problems facing coral reefs it will
be possible to rebuild reefs that have
been damaged
amazing stuff do stay tuned coming up
after the break i'll be joined by dr
cece who from the university of oxford's
environmental change institute and
richard black senior associate at the
energy and climate intelligence unit and
we're going to be discussing phasing out
fossil fuels and if we need to do more
to protect nature-based solutions
[Music]
of course predicting fertility is is
something that's really difficult but we
employ about 20
of our employees are over 50 and we
expect to have a really good uptake on
this policy we've only just launched the
policy so we've got shelley our
colleague who's going to be taking her
first leave this month and she's super
excited about it as we announce this to
our colleagues it was really well
received by our grandparents by our
parents and by our younger colleagues so
we're very positive about the difference
this could make
we've done lots of research here at saga
about this and and colleagues are
telling us that flexibility is really
important for them and of course in this
generation of over 50s often they're
looking after their their children their
grandchildren and sometimes looking
after their parents too so
statements like this are really
important as a responsible employer and
around age we hope not to be unique for
too long we think we're the first in the
uk if not in the world to do this um but
of course we would love more employers
to follow this because we recognize that
being an age friendly employer is simply
the right thing to do and of course
having more experienced colleagues helps
us serve our more experienced customers
so it adds some real value to our
business well we think it's simply about
being the right thing to do we need to
attract and retain
more colleagues into our workplace and
as you said people are going to be
working longer so well-being for all
organizations is a really important
priority and for us grandparents leave
is part of that
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
i love my job because
i get to do something that is
contributing to a better future
[Music]
did you know if we use less energy we
can reduce air pollution
like turning off the lights yep
[Music]
friday will start cold and showery with
a patchy frost but eastern britain will
be mainly dry
ireland northern ireland and western
britain will see showers through the
morning some heavy with hail and thunder
and hill snow possible much of eastern
scotland and eastern england will stay
dry and sunny it'll be cold and windy
for all
the afternoon will be similar but the
showers will ease going into the evening
low air pollution levels are expected
again measuring just two or three on the
daily air quality index
the air quality report sponsored by
phillips air purifiers
hello and welcome back to the daily
climate show on sky news now we're
getting straight to discussing the
climate issues of the day now with dr
cece who from the university of oxford's
environmental change institute and
richard black senior associate at the
energy and climate intelligence unit so
good to see you both good evening
so let's uh talk about the spectacular
pictures today of scotland's last
coal-fired power station being
demolished and coal is very close to
complete extinction in fact in the uk
but this country like most others
continues to rely on other fossil fuels
mainly oil and gas for energy
but there's pressure to reduce that in a
bid to cut emissions and slow climate
change and this week's the uk's oil and
gas strategy was challenged in court by
campaigners and richard what was this
court case all about and is litigation
generally likely to have some sort of
influence on on speeding up our
transition towards renewables do you
think
yes this court case was brought by a
group called paid to pollute and the
basis of their case is that basically if
you look at the way that um the oil and
gas industry intersects with the
treasury some years it ends up paying
paying tax net to the treasury of the
years it ends up taking tax net from the
treasury so the plaintiffs in this case
are basically organ
arguing that in the years when it
actually receives money this is a
perverse incentive effectively it's
paying oil companies to get stuff out of
the ground at the very time when
scientists and
various other analyses are basically
saying we shouldn't be getting so much
oil and gas out of the ground in fact we
shouldn't be doing any more exploration
and development if we are just to have
you know enough fossil fuels that can
keep us but over 1.5 celsius limit so
they had the hearing yesterday and we
should be getting a judgment maybe
tomorrow maybe maybe in a week or two
and richard briefly i mean there's court
cases around the world are they making a
difference to government policies
i think some have made a big difference
the big one was the agenda co-op case
brought against the dutch government a
couple of years back which actually
really forced the government to
accelerate its carbon cutting
pledges but often the court cases raise
publicity about an issue and that can be
as useful in the long run as actually
winning and that i think is probably the
case with this paid to pollute one that
we're seeing you know the subsidy regime
is quite murky and this will will i
think you know shine some light upon it
cece what do you think do you think that
this is basically down to governments
making decisions about transitioning
away from fossil fuels or can other
influences
be important like public pressure for
example
yeah i think these cases are perfect
demonstration of people power right i
think people power all um can be very
strong and effective but the challenge
that we face is um how can we scale
people power i think um basically we
don't just want one successful case or
two successful cases we want lots of
cases and lots of individual actions and
um the the trouble with that is that you
know um it's hard to scale people power
um but i think one of the key issues
that we need to address in in this
challenge is that we need to really make
this mental linkage between climate
change which is a very abstract uh
concept with individual lives and you
know how does climate change reduce food
on your tables how does climate change
stop your children from going to school
once every individual has made that
mental link i mean i struggle struggle
with it sometimes too um even after
starting climate change for so many
years um once people have made that
mental link between that abstract
concept um and their daily lives then
they can make really individual changes
they can all be their organizations they
can log into their workplaces they can
lobby their governments um so i think
this is great
sorry to cut you off cc but just a quick
word on that issue with richard because
the government might say well well yes
but we need to worry about energy
security that relates to people they
might worry about getting a steady
supply of electricity people in the
fossil fuel industry will worry about
their jobs i mean people can relate to
that too the transition has to be
managed carefully doesn't it
yes it does and we've seen examples of
course in the uk how not to do it with
the phase out of cold mining uh going
back several decades that was a really
disruptive and and very unfair
transition germany chile other countries
are moving off of coal via other routes
basically consultations with mining
communities working out what support
they need in order to get through this
but i think it's also it's also
important to look at the overall scale
of likely job losses if you compare the
size of the workforce in the uk oil and
gas industry for example it's nothing
compared with a number of workers in
retail who've lost their jobs over the
last 10 20 years as online retailing has
become a thing so yes let's have a
transition and a just transition but
actually really let's make it a genuine
transition okay let's move on to our
next topic and earlier in the show we
heard how some traditional trees could
disappear from the british countryside
forever as changing weather patterns are
creating ideal conditions for diseases
to spread the national trust says it's
trying to build woodlands that are more
resilient to our changing climate but
it's enough being done to protect the
world's natural solutions and cece i
know you've done a lot of work on
adaptation i mean how important a role
can nature play in those projects trying
to mitigate against the effects of
climate change
yeah sure um so there are many um
nature-based solutions such as you know
one can build uh rain gardens or green
roofs or permeable roads and these are
roads basically that absorb a lot of
water um so um in terms of i actually
like to highlight a um initiative which
is happening in china right now which is
a country i study quite a bit um the
government has launched a one trillion
investment in um this initiative called
the sponge city initiative but basically
it's building it's finding new ways of
building city services and roads which
will absorb water that stops from you
know floods um and it's quite kind of
like a
a new way of kind of constructing cities
um and by 2030 the government is
actually aiming to have eighty percent
of its urban areas um to be sponge-like
so these cities will absorb water you
know flood water i mean in essence um um
very quickly and um there are some
preliminary results that are showing
that the investment in this kind of
resilience programs um are yielding 20
up to 20 times um investment returns so
it's really worth investing in in this
kind of resilient programs because they
give you a lot of avoided damages
cece very briefly i mean we were hearing
about the national trust warning about
diseases in trees the problem is though
that climate change might affect some of
those nature-based solutions might may
very briefly if you can yeah
oh yeah i mean trees are very you know
the lungs of the planets right we need
to protect them so um i think one a
nature-based solution is to not
kind of plant more trees um and in fact
a study has shown um if you plant a
trillion trees we can have the potential
to save the planet and at least to keep
our you know global temperature rise um
below 1.5 degrees um it it has the
potential to destroy but we need to need
to protect trees okay very quickly um
richard i mean
obviously nature plays a big part in
mitigating against the effects of
climate change but it can be affected
deeply by it as well
yes and we need to understand that for
all kinds of reasons we rely upon nature
you know for a lot of the food that we
eat we rely on you know we need healthy
soil we need insect pollinators and all
of these things we know that wildlife is
shifting its ranges and and in response
to climate change we need to understand
that and adapt to it because basically
we need to you know humanity to be able
to survive well you know in the nature
of 40 50 years time as well as it does
now
we're out of time i'm so sorry to keep
cutting in we were short of time but
cece and richard always good to talk to
you both thanks very much indeed
and do you stay with us guy news tonight
is up next and a panel of experts will
be answering all your questions about
the new omicron variant of covid19
thanks for watching see you next time
[Music]
you